according to chinese legend a magical
turtle once emerged from a river
with this special arrangement of dots
and lines on its shell
there's a secret mathematical property
to this pattern
if we count the number of dots in each
group we can write the numbers in an
array
now if we add up the numbers in the
first row they add up to 15.
the same goes if we add up the numbers
in the second row or the third row
in fact
if you add up the numbers in any of the
columns they also add up to 15 and the
same goes if you add up the numbers in
either of the diagonals
this is a magic square it's also known
as a low shoe square
this pattern also holds a very special
property which the ancient chinese
discovered
hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to show you how you can make a
9x9 magic square using the low shoe
technique
we'll illustrate the method to create a
3x3 magic square
the first step is to write the numbers
in ascending order starting from the
column on the right
now rotate the numbers 45 degrees
counterclockwise
to make a diamond shape
the third step is to swap the numbers
that are in the corners of this diamond
so the numbers 1 and 9 are in the
corners we'll go ahead and swap them
we'll also swap the numbers 7 and 3
which are in the corners
the final step is to compress these
numbers back into a square
so we'll bring the 3 and 7 in and we'll
bring the 9 and 1 in
and this is a magic square
that's 3 by 3.
all of the numbers add up to 15 in each
row and each column
and the diagonals
just because this method will be
important we'll go through the steps one
more time
you write the numbers one through nine
in order
then you rotate the numbers
to create a pyramid shape
swap the numbers in the corners
and finally compress the numbers back
into a square
so we can use this technique to build a
nine by nine square
how do we do that
the first step is to write the numbers
one to eighty-one
in each column we're going to write nine
numbers in increasing order
now we will focus on the numbers only in
the first row
there are a total of nine numbers here
and now we can use the low shoot
technique to create a three by three
magic square from these 9 numbers
so let's go ahead and do that
we'll write the numbers in increasing
order starting from the column on the
right
then we will rotate these numbers 45
degrees counterclockwise to create a
diamond shape
we'll swap the numbers in the corners
and finally we'll compress this back
into a square
and this is a magic square
that involves the numbers from the first
row
the next step is to repeat the exact
same process
for the numbers in the second row
so we could write out these numbers in
ascending order starting from the column
on the right rotate them swap the corner
elements and put them back into a square
but there's a nice trick we can use
that's a shortcut
notice that all of the numbers in the
second row are exactly one more than the
numbers in the first row
so
74 is one more than 73 65 is one more
than 64 and so on
so how can we create a magic square from
the numbers in the second row
well the trick we can use is we can
simply add one to all of the numbers in
the magic square we've just created
because we're adding one to each element
this will still create a magic square
the sum will just be three more in each
row
so this will be a magic square that
involves all the numbers from the second
row
and you can see where this is going we
can actually create three by three magic
squares for every single row
for the numbers one through nine
so i'm not going to do that right now
that'll be too many numbers to put on
the screen
but just keep in mind we can do that and
we're go that's how you can use the low
shoe method to create three by three
magic squares of every single one of
these nine rows
once you create these three by three
squares the question is how are you
going to position them to create a nine
by nine magic square
so the next step is to position these
three by three squares
so notice in the original magic square
we have the numbers one through nine and
there are nine rows that we want to put
three by three grids
so we look where the one is
this magic square that we've created has
a one
and the one in the original magic square
is in
the last row in the second column
so we're going to delete that one and
put this entire magic square this three
by three magic square in that position
we're going to repeat this for the
number two
so the number two is in the upper right
corner of the original magic square
so we're going to delete that element
and now we need to put in the three by
three magic square that involves the
number two
we obtain that by adding one to every
single number of the three by three
magic square that involves one
we then repeat the process for the
number three
the number three is in the second row in
the first column
we delete it and now we create a three
by three magic square involving the
number three which we obtained by adding
one to each of the elements of the three
by three magic square involving the
number two
so this is kind of a recursive method to
create a nine by nine magic square
and now we repeat this process for the
numbers four five six seven eight and
nine
so i'll go ahead and skip all these
steps and this is the result you get
this is a nine by nine magic square
which is built up from small three by
three magic squares
that we started out using the low shoe
technique
and
each of these three by three magic
squares is a magic square itself
and i put in bold where the numbers are
so we have four nine two three five
seven
eight one and six and those come from
the original magic square which was on
the our magical turtle
now the amazing thing is that this nine
by nine arrangement of numbers
every single row column and diagonal
adds up to 369
and this is absolutely amazing
to do this by chance would be
astronomically low the odds of it are
just so low
so this is
a really interesting way that they came
up to develop a nine by nine magic
square using the low shoe technique
it's a very clever algorithm
and it builds up from the original three
by three magic square to make a nine by
nine magic square
the best part is that the steps of the
three each process were easy to remember
so it's something you could reconstruct
any time
and it's really amazing that the ancient
chinese were able to come up with this
method
thank you for watching i hope you like
this video please subscribe to my
channel i make videos on math and game
theory
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions
you can also follow mind your decisions
on facebook google plus and patreon
you can catch me at preshtalwalker on
twitter instagram tumblr and pinterest
and please check out my books there's a
link in the video description i write
books about math puzzles and different
mathematical topics and i think you'll
really enjoy them